[Music]
jordan how is it going for you so far
um yeah i'm very happy of course uh i
just lost to magnus which is a pity
because you know you're looking forward
to especially playing magnus i would say
and then
didn't really manage to put any
resistance but in the first round today
i managed to beat the palace which is of
course
a big moment and um overall i'm very
satisfied yeah i mean you were leading
after the first round then how was this
feeling you were sharing the first place
with uh i didn't really get to enjoy it
because i immediately had to play uh
magnus with black so
i didn't really put any thought in that
but yeah overall i'm of course very
happy despite losing to magnus just now
yeah um what about yesterday evening did
you get some comments from your fans
your friends
not too many maybe from some close
friends but
no i just keep it like rather quiet and
i only message maybe with my family a
little bit that's it
tomorrow we're going to have also blitz
tournament and i was just wondering
which format do you prefer
oh i prefer blitz but i'm much better in
rapid i'm afraid so i like to play blitz
but it's uh i think it's my worst time
control so
kind of looking forward but also you
know i'm a bit bit scared that it's
gonna fall to pieces there but we'll see
yeah and today it's still on that round
to go against my plane i'm playing
so it's not gonna be
easy yeah
so what are your expectations
i just try not to lose i guess and then
that's about it i'll just try to play a
normal game yeah thank you so much all
the best of luck for you thank you
you